so we're getting a red Goblin Carnage
symbiote in this story and it's amazing
so this is the official start of Carnage
range this is the crossover event
between Miles Morales Spider-Man and
Carnage or at least Cletus Cassidy
remember the main Carnage symbiote is
out there in space achieving insane
levels of power and basically becoming
God that's going to go into the war of
the symbias this summer so don't forget
about that but the thing about this is
this initially opens up with Miles
Morales Rick hauling his last experience
with the Carnage symbiote because it's
not the first time they've met a lot of
people in the comments didn't realize
that but remember during the events of
King and black absolute Carnage all that
kind of stuff Miles Morales became a
Grendel he became part of the Carnage
symbiote at one point in time and in
fact he attacked Venom during that story
so lest we forget miles has met Carnage
before but the thing about this is that
it terrifies him because remember the
big difference between Venom and Carnage
is Venom is just like a symbiote that
was once bonded the Spider-Man
Spider-Man got rid of it in the old web
of Spider-Man stories and Venoms hated
him ever since Carnage is an answer to
the question what happens if the Joker
becomes Venom it's just this unbridled
pure unadulterated murderous rage and
that's literally what miles reflects on
right that it's just Madness and
Slaughter and there's no bargaining or
reasoning with it now remember because
this is Cletus Cassidy with what's
technically the extrembiote Symbiote
meaning the Symbiote that was created by
Iron Man that in effect it's not truly
Carnage but the principle Remains the
Same right the core of Carnage's
Insanity was Cletus Cassidy and so of
course Miles Morales leaps into action
exactly the way you think he would now
remember in the last video that we
covered and you'll find a link to that
below the like button here on YouTube
that Miles showed up to this Diner where
Cletus Cassidy had basically massacred
60 people in five minutes but when miles
gets there the whole place is fine and
there are just people who were going
about doing their thing eating their
food and so it seems a little strange to
him when suddenly Cletus comes out of
nowhere and that's when miles realizes
the whole thing is an illusion lest we
forget the extremely old symbiote that
Cletus is able to utilize he can
basically extrapolate it out to anything
he wants it to be so what he did is he
fabricated this entire environment miles
was walking into a trap and had no idea
it was happening when the Trap sprung
all bets are off enter Matt gargan the
Scorpion weird right so the Scorpion's
one of these weird characters in Marvel
Comics where sometimes he's a good guy
sometimes he's a bad guy when he became
Venom in Marvel Comics that was cool
superior Spider-Man punched his jaw off
his face and then basically doc realized
that uh Spider-Man was pulling his
punches the whole time but the thing
about this is that scorpion leaps in and
actually helps out Spider-Man in this
fight against Cletus so much so that had
that not happened miles would have died
because miles does not have the
wherewithal that Peter Parker has he
hasn't faced off against these guys so
he doesn't exactly know what to expect
now of course the one time shows up
right right the cops they show up here
and uh they try to bring some order to
the chaos Cletus Cassidy helps all these
guys finish with all their living and
Matt gargan finally makes his move now
one of the things to know is that sure
the Scorpion being here is able to help
miles but it's not enough to like turn
the tide of battle it's not enough to
make it so that miles is guaranteed to
win if anything it allows miles to
basically get out of there while he
can't now scorpion ends up retreating as
well but this leads to Miles asking the
question why did you even help me out in
the first place right like why are you
here assisting me and the reality of
scorpion is like I kind of owed a favor
right and that's basically it right he's
kind of here to a degree as a favor for
Miles now it is bigger than that and
we'll find out how much bigger this is
here in a little bit but what ends up
happening is of course Carnage makes the
return the fight kind of picks up again
not a whole lot doing here but one of
the big things that happens is Miles
hits clean his Cassidy with the Venom
blast and that's enough to kick-start
the Arc Reactor and send Clues Cassidy
running now let's explain this for a
second why does Cletus Cassidy have an
arc reactor Rob that's Iron Man Tech
right yes because remember the extreme
diode armor that Cletus Cassidy has was
created by Iron Man and it was powered
by an arc reactor Cletus doesn't fully
understand what that means but with
Miles having his electric Venom blast it
does overload it now what seems to be
going on here is Cletus Cassidy seems to
be immune to the traditional weaknesses
of a symbiote which is fire but not
enough of the arc reactor blast right
when this thing goes off it literally
explodes takes out like a whole city
block and it forces Cletus Cassidy to
retrieve now while Miles Morales and
Matt gargan are kind of digging
themselves out of the rubble and trying
to find survivors where they can when
they can and then of course finding some
way to get back to Cletus Cassidy you
switch over to the introduction of agent
GAO now it's not really the first time
we've seen her it's more of a return of
her character she's not overly important
here she works for a guy named Mr hang
who was at one point in X-Men villain
still kind of is to it agree those two
aren't super important what is important
is the anti-vigilante task force that
agent gal leads and the Sentinels that
Mr hang has that he's going to bring in
later on here in a little bit but the
thing about the anti-vigilante task
force is you basically have like Electro
at least Maxine so like the female
version of Electro now alongside
Taskmaster and in hightail who can just
run at super speed but the purpose of
this group is to one part hold
superheroes and super villains
accountable and then offer some kind of
a role that's similar to like damage
control but not exactly the big thing
here is that these guys jump in not only
that Matt gargan is more or less part of
this and that's why he's here but
something to understand is that where
Cletus Cassidy was forced to retreat
initially he didn't really care about
Miles Morales if anything attacking and
killing miles would draw a whole bunch
of attention to everything he's doing
which is really what he was looking for
right putting on an audience and showing
the world how dangerous he can become
now that Miles was able to get the upper
hand it's become a personal Vendetta
it's become a Desire by Cletus to go
directly after miles but before he can
do any of that he's got to figure out
what he's going to do with The Arc
Reactor in his chest that needs some
measure of repair and so what he ends up
doing is basically going to a Tony Stark
black site now one of the things to
understand about Iron Man is Iron Man
has all kinds of different suits he's
got all kinds of different technology
arms and armaments so on and so forth
but these are all scattered at different
places throughout the world one because
New York is a major hub for just
terrible things happening right like
every time you've seen a massive event
happen in Marvel New York's always the
first place they go after and two who
knows how things would progress a good
example is Age of Ultron right so the
world can collapse very easily having
different arms and Technology spread
across the world is the safest bet for
making sure that you always have
redundancies backups in case things go
south Cletus showing up here is just one
of these sites now what ends up
happening is he takes one of the guys
out then he tells another guy named Pete
that he basically needs to have this Arc
Reactor technology so sorted out he
doesn't fully understand it but what he
does say is put me in one of those Iron
Man Sentinels now this is kind of like a
side project that Tony Stark was working
on but it was built on the technology
that was partially developed by Mr hang
again we'll talk more about that here in
a little bit but the reality here is
these guys don't fully know how to
handle the Arc Reactor technology
because that information isn't shared
right it's not as though Tony Stark is
sending this technology out to his staff
showing them the ins and outs of how his
most prized possession functions it
doesn't work that way so while they're
all exceedingly intelligent the best
they can do is try to find some way to
fix this technology or at the very least
up the abilities of Carnage for the
purpose of allowing him to operate
within this Sentinel there are some
measures of restraint right they're not
granting him full access to everything
and they're only doing this because
their lives are on the line but one of
the other things that happens is really
kind of weird is that basically Cletus
Cassidy ends up giving uh Kenneth Neely
a portion of his symbiote again Kenneth
Neely was just like a fanboy right this
guy's like simply being all over Carnage
and Cletus capacity bit off more than he
can chew and he's effectively regretting
his decisions ever since but the big
point about this is that you end up
having the task force that shows up here
and faces off against Cletus Cassidy yet
again but these guys are overcome with a
quickness Taskmaster actually seems to
stand a pretty solid chance despite
having no powers other than the ability
to mimic the fighting style of anybody
he faces off against the best chance for
Hope here even with the intervention of
Miles Morales and Matt gargan showing up
in the midst of this conflict actually
comes down to Maxime it comes down to
the new Electro because having the
ability to manipulate electricity and
then while it's not necessarily enough
to destroy clueless Cassidy it is
certainly enough to send him running
away or at least to shut down the
Sentinel that he's bonded to at the end
of the day it doesn't matter and it
doesn't make any difference the reason
for this is that while the ability for
Carnage to access the entirety of the
world was effectively limited it did not
stop him from being able to access all
of the Stark redundancies right they're
kind of neural connections that exist
out there right so like imagine the
internet except only Tony Stark is able
to access it and it doesn't tie into the
main internet as a whole but what this
does is it allows Cletus Cassidy to tap
into the entirety of the Stark Network
it's not that dissimilar from what you
saw Ultron do in the Age of Ultron movie
except it is not the Internet it's just
Stark's own sort of networking system
but it's close enough because one of the
things to remember here is that Tony
Stark bought Parker Industries Why does
that matter because in the aftermath of
Secret Wars 2015 Peter Parker ran Parker
Industries it was a multinational
multi-billion dollar company it made him
richer than Tony Stark they sold all
kinds of devices phones laptops the
whole nine yards it all ended up going
to funked Tony Stark bought the remains
and because it's part of the Stark
system people are still using these
phones now Cletus Cassidy has the
ability to tap into all of them and in
effect he can basically create his own
own kind of virus so to speak and create
an army of Cletus cassidies which is
exactly what he's doing but what this
does is it actually switches over to
Normie Osborne so for those of you guys
who are not familiar with Normie Osborne
he of course is related to Norman
Osborne the Green Goblin he's actually
his grandson they're not exactly alike
and in fact in the Venom stories Normie
was given his own symbiote by the son of
Eddie Brock Dylan Brock so in effect
Normie Osborne is the red Goblin he's
like a Green Goblin but red and he's
basically a good guy he functions
throughout the city of New York trying
to help people where he can when he can
but the kicker about this is that what
the younger brother of Normie answering
the phone and includes Cassidy being the
one to call and then in turn using his
own powers to kind of ensnare the sun
this leads to Normie getting involved
realizing something bigger is going on
here and so what you end up getting is
the red Goblin teaming up alongside
Miles Morales and the Scorpion as well
as the Vigilante task force all for the
purpose of going after Cletus Cassidy
now the there's two things that I want
to specify here number one again this is
not Carnage if it was this fight would
have been over before it even started
and number two a lot of you guys are
probably asking where's Iron Man in the
midst of all of this seemingly Iron
Man's just not really involved in this
because this kind of thing is just not
overly important to him right it's kind
of it's kind of below him in terms of
the stuff that he concerns himself with
but the thing about this is that with
Cletus Cassidy tapping into all these
phones laptops the whole nine yards this
allows him to ensnare basically everyone
so the entirety of the city of New York
descends into absolute Madness this
leads to Mr hang bringing his Sentinels
into the equation for the purpose of one
taking down Cleo's Cassidy and then two
actually seminating a virus out there or
kind of cure that will basically
alleviate everybody of all these issues
that they're dealing with with regards
to the influence of Cletus Cassidy but
the first thing that has to be done is
to sever Cletus from this larger Network
right to remove his ability to tap into
phones and all that kind of stuff and to
keep him from being able to access
people themselves now one of the funny
things about this is that for red Goblin
and Miles while all this madness is
going on they're initially focusing on
Kenneth again Kenneth is not overly
important to all of this but he does
have a portion of the clueless Cassidy
Symbiote and so Miles initially tries to
pull it off of him right like literally
Kenneth jump starts his own boot Jets
and then goes to try to fly away and
miles is like holding on to the Symbiote
hoping It'll like rip off of Kenneth as
Kenneth just takes off but it doesn't
happen this is when red Goblin steps in
so one of the powers that the red Goblin
has in addition to his traditional
symbiote Powers is the ability to absorb
other symbiotes and so he literally
takes this symbiote from Kenneth and
absorbs it into himself he becomes a
Carnage red Goblin hybrid It's pretty
dope because one his look changes right
like literally the physical appearance
changes and it looks pretty awesome but
two lest we forget whenever a person is
bonded to a symbiote they will
inevitably take on the attributes of
that symbiote in this case of Normie
it's only a matter of time before he
starts to succumb to Madness if he's not
able to get rid of that Symbian the
other part of this is that if he is able
to keep it and he is able to control it
it'll make him one of the most powerful
symbiote beings out there in Marvel
Comics this kid's power will basically
be next level and so with Kenneth Neely
defeated and then handed over to the
cops and just kind of whisked away to a
mental asylum in the midst of all of
this now the only real major threat is
Cletus that's when the Sentinels come
into play now because they're dealing
with Cletus Cassidy himself it allows
like miles and Scorpion and the
anti-vigilante task force to really
focus more on the individual people
trying to keep them from hurting
themselves and keep them from hurting
others and so while they're doing more
like damage control than anything else
for the Sentinels it doesn't quite work
out the way that Mr hang initially
thought that they would that because the
Sentinels are based on Stark Tech but
also just ridiculously Advanced forms of
technology right like metal plating and
all the kind of stuff that goes with it
some adamantium and vibranium thrown in
there for good measure that they are
immediately eradicated or at least one
of them is totally destroyed by Cletus
Cassidy that shouldn't be able to happen
but remember the Symbiote that Cletus
has descends directly from Nola symbiote
God it's not like Venom and it's not
like Carnage where it's like a secondary
symbiote that was given to him by
somebody else it's way more powerful
than symbiotes traditionally are in
Marvel that's one of the things to
remember there's a kind of hierarchy
when it comes to the power that a
symbiote has you have like the king in
Black which was at one point null the
Symbiote God now it's Eddie Brock Venom
that's happening in the Venom stories
make sure you guys check out the link
below the like button we'll have that
posted as well but this hierarchy starts
with the king in black and then it
starts going down the line through
various symbiotes which order that takes
depends on how the stories are being
written so it's not an absolute
hierarchy but like the traditional Venom
symbiote is pretty high up then the
Venom symbiote gave birth to the Carnage
symbiote which is one of the reasons why
the Carnage symbiote is so incredibly
powerful enhanced levels of durability
speed shape-shifting things along those
lines and so what you're talking about
here with regards to the Symbiote that
Cletus Cassidy has is it's second to the
king in black meaning it's just under
the level of power that no previously
had and that Eddie Brock has right now
but the kicker here is that even though
one of the Sentinels are destroyed that
the other Sentinel is able to remain
operable just long enough to infect
Cletus Cassidy and shut down his access
to all these different internet-based
devices using Stark's back doors and so
this basically confines Cletus back to
being his normal self or at least his
symbi itself and all these different
human beings go back to being normal the
result here is that that symbiote's
destroyed and Miles Morales Matt gargan
and red Goblin have to flee for their
life now remember when I told you that
this whole conflict was beyond Tony
Stark I kind of lied because what we do
is we transition over to Iron Man
because he's watching all of this unfold
and he realizes what's going on is
Cletus Cassidy has hijacked his own
network this Cletus Cassidy is using
Stark Tech and Cletus Cassidy is
attacking the entire city of New York so
the question that has to be asked here
is what happens to Cletus Cassidy when
the man who controls the very symbiote
that he uses shows up in this conflict
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace